a magnitude 6.4 earthquake shook Western
Nepal on Friday the Tremors were felt in
the capital Katmandu and as far away as
New Delhi the districts of jarot and
rukum West in the remote carnali
Province were hottest hit many people
spent the night outside in the
cold I was asleep when I suddenly felt
the shaking I got up and tried to run
but was caught in the collapsing
debris the Prime Minister and several
MPS flew in to assess the damage and
offer their condolences to affected
communities they were accompanied by
Medical Teams from the
Army our primary focus is to rescue the
injured provide treatment and distribute
relief materials all the teams are
working
hard as local hospitals struggle to
treat the injured health personnel from
other parts of the country have been
deployed as
reinforcements dozens of severely
injured have been airlifted to bigger
hospitals in nearby towns Nepal is among
the most vulnerable countries to
earthquakes as the tectonic plates
beneath its young mountains continue to
shift in their formation earthquakes are
increasingly being felt across the
country Jer kot and rukum West are in a
remote and underdeveloped part of Nepal
making search and rescue operations
challenging the remoteness of the area
uh in the scattered uh nature of the um
villages
habitats so uh these are um creating
little bit challenge to the Troops as
winter approaches authorities have
appealed to International humanitarian
organizations to help with relief
efforts Ramat limbu Al jaaz
Katmandu make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer